[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régional et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
des territoires spécial ici au Congrès
des départements de France à Strasbourg
trois présidents de département chenes
kirouni bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes la présidente
socialiste du département de la Meurth
etmos Gan de guerri bonjour merci d'être
là président LR du département de lin et
Frédéric Bierry qui nous accueille chez
lui merci Frédéric Bierry président de
cette collectivité européenne d'Alsace
dont on vient de parler on a beaucoup de
sujets à aborder avec vous on va parler
de la décentralisation des finances des
aides sociales mais d'abord de la
question des mineurs non accompagnés des
mineurs étrangers isolés c'est l'un des
sujets de ce congrès alors que le Sénat
examine en ce moment même la loi
immigration et qu'il en a beaucoup été
question hier soir en séance euh et on
va voir comment ça se passe dans les
départements Jérôme Rabier s'est rendu
du côté de Nice car en 2023 le nombre de
migrants mineurs non accompagnés a
explosé dans les Alpe maritime un enjeu
important pour le département qui a
obligation de les prendre en charge au
titre de la protection de l'enfance et
pour la police aux frontières qui doit
assurer un dispositif particulier on
regarde les Alpes maritimes sont le
principal point d'entrée de migrant en
France alors à la frontière
franco-italienne sur route dans les
montagnes ou dans les trains les
contrôles sont permanents ici en garde
menton Gard avant de nombreuses forces
de police opèrent un contrôle strict
c'est le première première gare en
entrée France donc on a un contrôle
systématique de tous les trains qui vont
passer ici par menton gare avant pour
être contrôler parce que 70 % à 80 % de
des entrées irrégulières se font par ce
point de passage messieur bonjour c'est
un contrôle de police vous pouvez nous
sortir une carte d'identité s'il vous
plaît dans ce trainlà aucun migrant mais
quand ils ont moins de 18 ans une prise
en charge spécifique doit avoir lieu et
cette année ce sont plus de 5000 mineurs
qui ont déjà été interpellés en fait le
majeur il est non admi donc on lui
notifie un refus d'entrée on le renvoie
en italiion le mineur en fait on on
considère qu'il est sous la sous notre
protection et la protection après du
département et donc le temps où nous il
est dans nos locaux on on a un espace
qui est dédié au mineurs et dans lequel
on va on va attendre sa prise en charge
par le Conseil département
une fois conduit au poste de la police
aux frontières il doit franchir une
première étape c'est un cas unique en
France une
expérimentation une première
appréciation de la minorité à lieu par
les équipes du
département les personnes sont
interroger sur leurs conditions de vie
au pays sur leur parcours migratoire
leur autonomie le but étant de réunir le
faisceau d'indice nécessaire à rendre la
vie que nous donnerons à la police aux
frontières avec cette appréciation la
police au frontière décide ou non de
renvoyer en Italie pour ceux qui sont
considérés comme mineurs une nouvelle
étape s'organise la police aux
frontières les confie à la collectivité
départementale au service de la
protection de l'enfance en quelques
années les équipes ont vu le nombre
d'arrivées explosé on est passé de
environ 1800 entrées en 2019 à plus de
6200 entrées seulement au 31 octobre de
l'année 2023 avec un chiffre attendu qui
tournera en fin d'année à 7500 mineurs
non accompagnés pris en charge par les
services
départementaux le premier défi est de
pouvoir mettre à l'abri ses mineurs 500
places sont prévues pour cet accueil
d'urgence s'il le faut des hôtels
complètent les installations pérennes
après ces premiers jours tous les
mineurs doivent avoir un entretien pour
encore s'assurer de leur minorité ce
jour-là ils sont une dizaine à avoir
rendez-vous on a une grille d'évaluation
qui effectivement reprend le parcours
reprend familial les raisons pour
lesquelles ils sont partis de leur pays
et leur projet éventuel en France on
peut compter environ un tiers des jeunes
qui sont reçus qui ne sont pas mineurs
une immense majorité de ces jeunes admi
mineurs ou non FuG dans les premiers
jours sur ceux qui restent et seront
pris en charge une moitié environ est
envoyé dans d'autres départements au
titre de la solidarité nationale les
autres sont confiés par un juge au
département qui it s'en occuper jusqu'à
leur 18 ans on a la prise en charge de
ces jeunes dans leur quotidien et dans
la globalité de leur vie on intervient
sur la question du logement on
intervient bien sûr sur tout ce qui
relève de leur scolarité de leur
formation des actes administratifs de
leur santé et puis on les prépare
évidemment à l'autonomie face au nombre
toujours plus important les coûts pour
le département explose une situation
intenable pour les élus et c'est un
problème qui est un problème d'État
alors soit l'État prend en charge
cette cet accueil soit il nous donne
davantage de moyens pour le faire parce
qu'aujourd'hui le budget a carrément
explosé entre l'année dernière et cette
année on était à 13 millions d'euros et
on en est à 28 le département des Alpes
Maritimes n'est pas le seul à tirer la
sonnette d'alarme l'Assemblée des
départements de France demande une
réforme dans la prise en charge de ces
mineurs non accompagnés voilà on a vu ce
sujet de Jérôme Rabier dans les Alpes
Maritimes évidemment un département
frontalier donc qui fait face à une
explosion des cas mais est-ce que ces
mineurs non accompagnés c'est une
difficulté de gestion pour l'ensemble
des départements Frédéric Berry oui ben
bien évidemment parce que on est sur un
effet volume qui a explosé on a une
expertise he de longu dates sur
l'accueil des mineurs non accompagnés
avec beaucoup de réussite hein c'est des
jeunes qui viennent et qui ont envie de
s'insérer dans le territoire on est un
peu un eldorado pour eux et donc on a de
très très belles réussites avec avec ces
jeunes mais aujourd'hui notre difficulté
elle est double c'estàdire à la fois en
protection de l'enfance classique on a
une augmentation du nombre d'enfants des
informations préoccupantes en en
augmentation et des des troubles du
comportement de plus en plus difficiles
à gérer et ce ce greffe là-dessus une
augmentation en volume très importante
chez nous on a doublé le nombre de MNA
en une année avec la difficulté de
recruter d'avoir suffisamment
d'établissements de lieux d'accueil
adaptés donc c'est c'est partic
parculièrement difficile et en même
temps pour nous c'est une mission qui
nous tient à cœur et on essaie de
trouver les meilleures solutions Jean de
Guer vous aussi qui frontalier est-ce
que est-ce que c'est compliqué à gérer
oui c'est très compliqué à gérer le
département de l' est un département
frontalier près de l'Italie mais aussi
dans plein dans la le couloir de la
vallée du rô donc ce remonte du Midi
également nous concerne ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que la situation a
vraiment évoluée depuis un an il est
arrivé au 1er septembre
2023 autant de mineurs non accompagnés
que durant toute l'année 2022 donc on
voit qu'il reste encore 4 mois à
comptabiliser c'est énorme et donc ce
qui vient d'être dit chez notre collègue
charlan ginésie dans les Alpes Maritimes
et se répercute partout en France le
problème aujourd'hui le premier défi en
dehors de l'aspect financier bien sûr
qui coûte très cher au département c'est
d'abord l'hébergement et là aujourd'hui
nous n'avons plus de possibilité je
parle dans l'un mais je sais que l'autre
département c'est la même chose d'avoir
de possibilité d'hébergement et nous
n'avons plus non plus de main d'œuvre
pour s'occuper de ces mineurs non
accompagnés parce que nos équipes
s'amenuisent parce que nos équipes se
fatiguent parce que nos équipes se
découragent et puis derrière et bien on
a même plus l'occasion de s'occuper de
nos propres mineurs dans nos
départements c'est là-dessus où le fait
devient très grave donc il faut
absolument que l'État nous vienne en
secours on va revenir sur les solutions
chez NES kirouniv vous comment ça se
passe du côté de la mur nous nous sommes
confrontés comme l'ensemble des
départements évidemment à une
augmentation du du nombre de mineurs non
accompagnés qui nous ont sollicité
depuis euh justement ces quelques mois
et notamment l'été moi je ne fais pas
d'opposition justement entre les mineurs
non accompagnés et le reste de nos
enfants à partir du moment où la
personne le jeune est évalué mineur il
intègre la protection de l'enfance et
avec effectivement les difficultés que
nous rencontrons dans le cadre de la
protection de l'enfance parce que je
veux aussi
euh dire de manière assez forte la
question de la protection de l'enfance
de l'accompagnement des places
d'hébergement les problématiques
d'attractivité des métiers des
travailleurs sociaux c'est une
problématique globale que nous
connaissons maintenant depuis de
nombreuses années nous le budget de la
protection de l'enfance de manière
encore une fois élargie MNA et les
autres en 10 an il a il a doublé et le
budget 2024 que je suis en train de
travailler que nous allons voter en
décembre il va également augmenter donc
oui il y a une problématique en lien
avec l'arrivée d'un certain nombre de
MNA mais moi j'ai besoin d'être
accompagné par l'État pour sécuriser les
parcours une fois qu'ils sont évalués
mineurs euh nous les prenons en charge
quand ils sont majeurs c'est à l'état de
prendre en charge et là la sécurisation
des parcours n'est pas toujours
justement très euh très précise ouais
mais mais qu'on comprenne bien t
qu'est-ce que vous attendez précisément
de l'état du gouvernement aujourd'hui
est-ce que ce sont des moyens financiers
pour vous aider à gérer est-ce que c'est
une reprise en main d'une partie
notamment de la période d'évaluation en
tout cas de mise à l'abri en attendant
l'évaluation qu'est-ce qu'il faut que
l'État fasse alors plusieurs plusieurs
choses d'abord les financements il faut
qu'on ait les financements adaptés c'est
c'est c'est lié à la politique
migratoire donc la charge financière de
l'accompagnement de ces enfants devrait
être complètement assumée financièrement
euh par l'État puisque c'est lié à la
politique migratoire qui est une
compétence régalienne euh euh l'é donc
vous gardez la gestion de l'évaluation
la mise à l'abri et vous demandez une
compensation g alors la la le moment
avant avant l'évaluation de la minorité
c'est à l'État nous demandons que l'État
assure la mise à l'abri mais dès lors
que la minorité est reconnue par pour
ses enfants c'est à nous de l'assumer et
pourquoi nous parce que tout simplement
on a une expertise sur ce sur
l'accompagnement de ces jeunes on a des
éducateurs qui qui qui font ce travail
là merveilleusement avec beaucoup
d'engagement donc on on a ce ce cette
cette euh cet ADN de de la protection de
l'enfance et donc on pense que on SAA
bien évidemment mieux le faire au regard
de l'expertise qu'on a sur la question
mais il faut qu'on a les financement
adaptés moi j'ai un désaccord sur de
quelle politique publique relèv les
mineurs non accompagnés pour moi il
relève de la protection de l'enfance en
revanche là où je rejoins mes collègues
c'est qu'à partir du moment où
l'évaluation détermine la majorité oui
l'État doit prendre ses responsabilités
concernant la mise à l'abri concernant
l'éberge ement et là je sais que nous
avons tous collectivement des
difficultés à accompagner et sécuriser
ceux qui sont mineurs et qui doivent
nécessiter justement une protection dans
le cadre de laaz la protection de
l'enfance par les départements et ceux
qui sont majeurs qui là relèv de la
responsabilité de de l'État au titre de
l'hébergement et au titre de la
politique migratoire Jean de guerri vous
là-dessus parce que du coup on a deux
positions qui sont un petit peu
différentes très bien moi je partage
bien évidemment ce qui vient d'être dit
notamment surtout de mon collègue
Frédéric Biry puisque pour moi le fait
de la politique migratoire relève de
l'État c'est un phénomène régalien c'est
de la responsabilité de l'État je dirais
même c'est la responsabilité de l'Europe
ensuite en ce qui concerne la protection
de cette enfance là oui il faut que le
gouvernement prenne en charge l'abri le
temps que nous évaluons parce qu'il faut
que l'évaluation reste à la charge des
départements pour des questions
d'efficacité de rapidité et de
connaissance aussi
et par la suite les jeunes qui sont vous
l'avez entendu dans le reportage plus
d'un tiers ne sont pas mineurs il faut
tout de suite que ça revienne de la
responsabilité de la charge de l'État
uniquement parce qu'aujourd'hui
accompagné des mineurs oui non jusqu'à
21 ans ce ne sont plus des mineurs et ça
ne doit pas en cette période de 18 à 21
ans être à la charge des départements
déjà ça nous donnera une bouffée
d'oxygène mais ça ne suffit pas il faut
qu'ensuite l'état intervienne davantage
financièrement auprès des départements
qui on va peut-être en parler tout à
l'heure sont au bord du gouffre au
niveau au niveau fin on va parler une
dernière tout de suite parce que vous
vous vous parlez notamment des mesures
qui ont été mises en place par la loi
taqué il y a aussi la mesure que du fait
que vous ne pouvez plus héberger à
l'hôtel ces mineurs est-ce qu'il faut
revenir là-dessus justement mais bien
sûr il faut absolument que la loi taqua
soit revu aujourd'hui plus aucun
hôtelier ne veut prendre nos mineurs
donc nous n'avons plus de maire qui
acceptte de nous donner ou nous prêter
des hébergements pour mettre ces pauvres
enfants donc on est quand même blé
d'accord
peut-être mais je je vaux d'abord
terminer mon propos si tu permet donc il
faut d'abord que la loiqu soit revue il
faut permettre toutes sortes
d'hébergement et si N dans je parle dans
l'un si je n'ai pas les hôtels pour
héberger ces jeunes là je ne sais plus
où les mettre et je suis en
responsabilité pénale face à ces enfants
don il faut quand même à un moment donné
dire les choses en face et qu'on trouve
les vrais moyens et arrêter de nous
pendre des choses qui derrière sont pas
applicables non mais je je je je je
partage pour partie hein il y a pas un
désaccord fondamental mais moi je crois
qu'on a aussi une problématique je le
disais de sécurisation des parcours à
partir du moment où on a un jeune qui
est accompagné qui est formé qui trouve
un employeur et bien on a une difficulté
aussi de remise en question des titres
de séjour si nous avions une fluidité de
l'octroi de titre de séjour quand le
jeune a été accompagné une évaluation
positive de cet accompagnement des
employeurs qui sont prêts à les intégrer
et à les recruter et bien dans ces
cas-là facilitons cette régularisation
et ça fera aussi une fluidité dans les
places qui sont proposées on a aussi un
embolisement parce que le parcours n'est
pas fluide peut-être si je peux revenir
sur l'hôtel c'est pas en soit on sait
très bien que la solution de l'hôtel
c'est pas la solution miraculeuse et si
on peut éviter l'hôtel on on essaie de
le faire mais à un moment donné quand
vous avez un flux aussi important que
celui auquel on est confronté on n' pas
on n' pas les solutions matérielles d'AC
est-ce qu'on préfère que les jeunes il
dorment dehors ou qu'il dorment dans les
hôtels nous on on on on défend plutôt
cette idée cette capacité quand on a pas
d'autres solution de pouvoir avoir une
solution dans un hôtel mais une solution
accompagnée dans un hôtel parce que nos
éducateurs peuvent aussi du coup
intervenir et puis sur le deème point
que chenes vient d'évoquer c'est vrai
que il y a il y a des questions de
parcours on a quand même souvent de très
belles réussites de parcours des MNA et
il faut pas par contre que au moment où
il pourrait intégrer un apprentissage et
cetera il soit on soit bloqué
juridiquement aujourd'hui pour le faire
donc il faut trouver aussi que que
l'État s'engage dans cette démarche là
parce que on a aujourd'hui des
situations les gamins on ils pourrai
être pris ils ont envie et on est bloqué
et là-dessus c'est c'est c'est quelque
chose à revoir on va parler de la
question des finances évidemment autre
sujet d'inquiétude des départements avec
une explosion de vos dépenses liées à
l'inflation lié aussi aux aides sociales
et un reste à charge qui s'accroit à
nouveau et dans le même temps vos
recettes qui diminuent notamment à cause
de la baisse de dynamique du marché
immobilier du fait que vos droits de
mutation à titre onéreux ce qu'on
appelle les frais de notaire sont en
baisse il y a cet effet de ciseau pour
le dire que doit dire ellisabeth Bor
qu'est-ce que vous attendez bah nous on
a besoin de revenir à l'esprit premier
de la décentralisation et l'esprit
premier de la décentralisation c'était
de rapprocher les décisions politiques
des citoyens et aujourd'hui pour mener
nos projets pour mener nos politiques
publiques pour pour mener nos missions
nous avons besoin de financement de
marge de manœuvre or aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus de marge de manœuvre
financière parce que nous n'avons plus
d'autonomie financière nous n'avons plus
de levés fiscaux et les politiques
publiques pour lesquelles nous attendons
les compensations de l'État je pense
notamment les allocations d'insertion
l'allocation personnes âgées
l'allocation prestation compensation
handicap et le RSA aujourd'hui ne sont
pas compensés à hauteur de ce que
devrait compenser l'état donc que l'État
prenne aussi ses responsabilités dans la
les compensations qui sont de sa
responsabilité pour nous donner du
souffle et des marges de manœuvre pour
mener notre projet et et ça fait des
années que les départements alertent sur
cette compensation des des aïes des
allocations individuelle de solidarité
notamment du RSA mais votre rest à
charge continue de s'accroître pourquoi
il y a pas de
solution déjà je vauxis être très clair
il faut que l'État arrête de décider et
de faire payer les autres ça c'est la
première la première des conditions
puisque'on l'a vu plus de 2 milliards et
demi d'euros à la charge des département
depuis l'année dernière sans
concertation avec les départements seule
la décision du chef de l'État et
derrière ce sont les départements qui
payent un notre vous l'avez justement
dit nous avons une baisse de recettes
vertigineuse à cause des chutes de de
MTO conjugué avec des hausses sociales
qui explosent on vient de parler des MNA
à l'instant c'est un coûpt énorme à la
charge du département conjugué avec
toutes les autres dépenses sociales
puisque dans un département comme le
mien qui 6000 nouveaux habitants chaque
année dans ces 6000 nouveaux habitants
j'ai des personnes handicapées j'ai des
gens bénéficiaires du RSA j'ai des
personnes âgées donc qui augmentent la
capacité financière de mes dépenses
derrière les fait ciseau arrivent il y
avait une quinzaine de départements qui
ét en souffrance l'an passé à cette même
époque je vous garantis qu'aujourd'hui
ça va être un sur de et je ne sais pas
combien ça sera l'an prochain donc il
est grand temps que le gouvernement
prenne conscience de ce qui arrive dans
nos dans nos territoires redéfinissent
les champs de compétences clairement de
chaque collectivité et donneent les
moyens de d'appliquer ses compétences à
chacun à chacune des collectivités c'est
ça le plus important c'est ça le plus
clair une fois qu'on aura redéfini tous
ces champs de compétences toutes ces
missions avec les financements qui
doivent accompagner et bien je pense que
tout le monde se portera beaucoup mieux
alors moi je pense qu'il faut dans dans
le même sens que mes mes collègu hein
mais d'abord une juste compensation des
évolutions des des dépenses sociales
parce qu'elles sont en en forte en forte
augmentation et il y a un enjeu de
solidarité nationale c'est à notre
échelle que la solidarité peut se faire
l'accompagnement de nos concitoyens les
plus fragiles peut se faire le mieux
mais on a besoin d'une compensation
financière du coût de de cette charge
donc la solidarité nationale doit
prendre en compte une partie de de de
bien évidemment de cette dépense nous
devons en plus de cel retrouver une part
d'autonomie fiscale avec une assise
territoriale parce que aujourd'hui on a
plus du tout de marge de manœuvre
c'estàd face à des dépenses
supplémentaires on a aucun levier donc
ça c'est pas possible qu'on puisse
rester dans cette logique là et
troisième élément quand
l'État et Jean vient de le dire l'État
décide d' de de prendre des décisions
qui vont avoir un impact sur nos
dépenses que ce soit compensé totalement
et durablement on peut pas accepter que
l'État décide d'augmenter le RSA et
c'est nous qui devons payer je vais vous
faire un cadeau et c'est gens qui va le
payer c'est ça finalement ce qu'on nous
propose c'est pas acceptable vous posez
la question de la décentralisation elle
a été reposée il y a quelques jours par
le chef de l'État qui a écrit une lettre
au chef de parti pour les convier à une
nouvelle rencontre de saint-emis et dans
cette lettre il a parlé d'une mission
qui était confiée à Eric vert sur la
décentralisation et notamment sur la
simplification territoriale est-ce que
c'est la bonne méthode Jean de
guerrier sur la décentralisation on a
dit beaucoup de choses et depuis forc de
constater qu'on assiste plutôt à une
recentralisation qui vraie
décentralisation or nous les
départements nous la réclamons depuis
toujours et depuis très longtemps donc
qu' aujourd'hui encore c'est je le
disais à l'instant il faut redéfinir les
compétences de chacun mais donner les
moyens de ces compétences à chacun mais
redéfinir les compétences ça veut dire
donner de nouvelles compétences au
département pas forcément ça veut dire
bien clarifier les compétences euh il y
a des compétences qui sont partager avec
plusieurs collectivités je prends
l'exemple du tourisme c'est un petit peu
vague c'est un petit peu compliqué mais
il faut que ce qui est du système
régalien comme la santé comme la
sécurité reste du domaine régalien et
soit vraiment appliqué que l'État
applique déjà ces vraie compét jusqu'au
bout et qu'ensuite il décide de le
social reste au département avec bien
sûr la gestion des routes et cetera mais
il faut vraiment définir les choses et
surtout donner les moyens d'appliquer
ces compétences là or aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas et comme le disait à
juste titre Frédéric Bierry il faut nous
redonner un levier fiscal nous sommes la
seule collectivité de France à ne plus
avoir de levier fiscal ce n'est pas
normal lequel alors on était sur le
fontier bâti dernièrement pourquoi pas
le restituer je n'en sais rien peut-être
une part tout pe disc de la SG c'est ce
que disait Jean-Luc gaise tout se peut
tout peut se se discuter on est bien
d'accord làdessus mais il faut nous
redonner les moyens d'appliquer nos
politique et puis enfin je pense que
maintenant il faut une pause une pause
on ne va pas à nouveau réouvrir un
chantier de réforme territoriale nous
avons suffisamment d'enjeux qui ont été
évoqués dans ce sur ce plateau donc
concentrons-nous justement sur ces
enjeux pour que nous puissions mener à
bien nos peut-être qu'il y a quelques
clarifications à faire nous avons besoin
de moyens mais ne nous engageons pas à
nouveau dans une nouvelle réforme
territoriale on a besoin d'une pause et
on a besoin de se concentrer sur des
enjeux comme le défi du vieillissement
de la population là nous attendons une
loi grand âge qui nous permet de N
projeter face à ce défi concentrons-nous
justement sur l'accompagnement des
allocataires du RSA concentrons-nous sur
l'inclusion et l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de handicap et
qu'on comprenne bien chees qu'ironie
pour vous cette mission vert du coup
elle est pas utile o est-ce je considère
qu'elle est pas utile en fonction de
l'objectif qui est supposé posé donc si
c'est à nouveau de redéconstruire
notre notre organisation territoriale
non je pense qu'elle n'est pas utile si
le travail est plutôt de de de nous
concentrer sur comment nous pouvons
faire mieux comment nous pouvons
sécuriser les moyens les moyens
financiers la méthode on se concentre
surtout surtout sur qui fait plutôt que
sur le comment bah concentrons-nous sur
le comment et en revanche oui les défis
sont beaucoup plus importants et c'est
un peu plus compliqué
frri j'aurais pas tout à fait le même
avis que que que chenes sur le sur le
sujet bon d'abord on voit bien une
attente très forte de nos concitoyens de
comprendre comment fonctionne l'action
publique les gens il faut qu'on arrive à
retisser nouer le lien démocratique avec
nos concitoyens et dans ce dans cet
esprit là la décentralisation peut avoir
du sens c'est vrai qu'il y a des
quelques inquiétudes parmi les
présidents de département et et à juste
titre on a été maltraité par les
dernières prétendues décentralisation on
s'est retrouvé avec finalement des
territoires contraints XXL on s'est
retrouvé avec des compétences qu'on nous
a retiré des moyens financiers et
fiscaux en moins donc forcément les élus
ont été échaudés ben personnellement moi
je défends l'idée du d' d'une
décentralisation qui correspond à la
volonté de nos concitoyens en Alsace
nous avons un un un vrai projet on a
d'abord fédéré nos nos deux départements
les les Alsaciens on les a questionné 92
% veulent le retour à une région Alsace
à part entière donc nous nous estimons
que nous avons le mandat de porter cette
démarche or je vois dans la lettre de
mission de Monsieur vert qui parle de
simplification du suppression d'une
strate nous on dit chiche on est prêt à
à à à porter une démarche de ce type là
au titre de la différenciation uel ma il
il a pas il a pas l'air de vouloir vous
suivre là-dessus ben écoutez il peut pas
avoir un discours qui dit il faut aller
dans sensel et que nous on réponde à
toutes les conditions et après dire
c'est pas possible chez vous donc moi je
suis persuadé qu'à un moment donné on va
écouter les on va écouter le territoire
quand vous avez 96 % des clubs qui
veulent des clubs alsaciens qui veulent
retrouver une ligue alsas de de de de
football on voit bien qu' il y a la
société civile il y a la volonté de la
population il y a il y a les le
territoire qui a su se rassembler on va
l'écouter parce que sinon c'est pas la
peine de parler de décentralisation et
d'écoute des territoires et et c'est
c'est peut-être pas la vie de tout le
grand test on va poser la la question à
ches kirouni est-ce qu'il faut que
l'Alsace quitte le grand estest
alors moi je veux être clair et redire
oui à la décentralisation et revenir à
l'esprit premier de la décentralisation
si la lettre de mission c'est
effectivement de revenir à l'esprit
premier de la décentralisation avec les
moyens qui vont avec bien sûr que je
partage le fait que nous puissions
travailler ensemble avec l'État pour
arriver à retrouver ce souffle et cette
marge de manœuvre après est-ce que il
est temps aujourd'hui de revenir à une
espèce de nouveau bing bang territorial
non je crois que nous avons besoin de
poser les choses je ne dis pas ça on a
bien compris che mais est-ce qu'il faut
que l'Alsace quitte le grand test ou
Pasi vous êtes favorable pense moi je
pense qu'on a besoin de l'Alsace dans le
grand test et je is le dire de manière
positive nous avons besoin dans le Grand
Est de l'Alsace et je pense que c'est
important que l'Alsace puisse être dans
le Grand Est et je ne crois pas même si
euh peut-être que il y a 5 6 ans 7 ans
on a fait peut-être effectivement et et
moi je je veux bien l'accepter que ces
régions XXL sont beaucoup trop larges
mais je parle maintenant d'aujourd'hui
en 2023 euh je ne crois pas que l'Alsace
ait perdu son identité nous sommes là
pour les assises départementales et bien
je vois bien et je suis heureuse de
partager la culture l'identité
spécifique alsacienne mais
euh moi ma réflexion elle est dans ce
temps présent et dans ce contexte
aujourd'hui Frédéric Berry après Jean de
Gueré c'est une pour moi c'est aussi
c'est une question d'efficacité de
l'action publique et de capacité à
emmener nos concitoyens si les gens ne
n'ont pas un sentiment d'appartenance à
territoire et là on est carrément sur un
mariage sans consentement moi je crois
pas est-ce que vous croyez au mariage
sans consentement moi je moi je n'y
crois pas ça peut pas être durable et
aujourd'hui il y a une volonté des
habitants elle doit être prise en
considération parce que sinon que
va-t-il se passer l'abstention va encore
augmenter le risque de que les
concitoyens se réfugent dans les voies
des des extrêmes voilà ce qui va se
passer et aujourd'hui ce que nous propos
c'est pas un projet contre les autres
l'alsa c'est naturell ement tourn vers
l'espace Renant ici on le voit bien au
Parlement européen l'enjeu frontalier
hier dans nos échanges et la Lorine la
champagneen est naturellement tourné
vers Paris vers vers la Belgique et
c'est naturel faut tenir compte aussi
des réalités géographiques c'est faux
non je peux je peux pas dire que la
Lorine est tourné vers Paris la Meur
Moselle la Mzelle est transfrontalière
avec le Luxembourg avec l'Allemagne avec
la Belgique donc on n'est pas nous
tourné vers Paris Jean de gu est-ce que
vous soutenez cette démarche de Biry et
est-ce que ça peut donner des des
véléités à d'autres je pense notamment à
vos voisins savoyard non moi ce que je
voulais dire surtout vous parliez de la
mission d'Eric ver tout à l'heure
j'espère surtout qu'elle va pas monter
les collectivités les unes contre les
autres c'est ce que je crains parce que
chacune a sa place que ça soit les
régions les départements les communes si
on définit redéfinit clairement leurs
compétences la population comprendra
très bien rappelez-vous parce que je
pense qu'on a un peu la mémoire un peu
courte rappelez-vous pendant la période
covid si les département n'avait pas été
là la gestion de la crise aurait été
bien plus compliquée nous avons été ici
pour fournir les pour les gel s'occuper
de ce qu'on pouvait faire c'était très
important tout simplement parce que les
départements comme les communes sont
véritablement la collectivité de
proximité par excellence et ça il faut
vraiment que nous puissions le conserver
et ce sera la conclusion de ce
débat